of their history rather than let history
take control of them and I think most
people will recognize that as an effort
to see the restoration of the devolved
government here there's been no power
sharing in government from in Northern
Ireland for more than a year because of
the difficulties that exist over the
Northern Ireland protocol the
post-brexit trading Arrangement which
the dup does not believe has been
adequately addressed by The Windsor
framework Rishi sunax deal with the EU
but Ursula vanderlen has been here as
well today so this is a combined effort
by presidents Prime Ministers past and
present to sell David I'm just gonna
have to interrupt you because has just
come on to the stage that's listening
agreement will always be remembered as
one of the most extraordinary political
achievements of our lifetimes
because step by step
faltering at first people on all sides
began to do things that were once
Unthinkable in the search for peace
you don't need me to tell you that
because many of you in this room created
it
it's humbling to be with you today
and with the people of Northern Ireland
who have endured so much
after three long decades where violence
and Terror are part of everyday life
a generation has grown up in a place
that is vastly more peaceful more
prosperous and more at ease with itself
now of course we meet here today in
circumstances that are far from perfect
but my argument today is this
the Belfast Good Friday agreement
Remains the best and only foundation for
peace and prosperity
and if we can take inspiration and
instruction from the way peace was
achieved 25 years ago
we can fulfill the true promise
enshrined in that agreement
the promise of stable devolved
government a prosperous economy and a
more united Society
that's the future for Northern Ireland
we must build
now to do that we must first ask why
why did peace talk succeed in 1998 when
so many had failed before
and I believe that's because people on
all sides showed courage imagination and
perseverance
first those who worked for peace had the
personal courage to keep going in spite
of daily threats to them and their
families and the political courage to
take risks in pursuit of a higher goal
John Hume over his entire career never
relented in his insistence on
non-violence
David Trimble took enormous risk to do
what he thought was right for the union
and they were rightly honored as the
preeminent architects of peace with a
joint Nobel Peace Prize
Jerry Adams and Martin McGuinness
persuaded Republicans to join a
constitutional power sharing assembly
and encouraged by the Intensive efforts
of Mo molam the leaders of loyalism also
lent their weight behind the deal
female leaders from the women for peace
in the women's Coalition worked so hard
for peace
and bertia Hearn showed the wisdom and
statecraft to see the historic
opportunity
at a critical moment he recognized
unionist concerns over the proposed
north-south arrangements and stepped
back
Trimble himself in his last public
appearance at this University just weeks
before he passed away embraced his old
counterpart and thanked Bertie for
giving him the space to act
these acts of courage
were more powerful than a thousand bombs
and bullets
because there is nothing glamorous about
violence there is nothing glorious about
Terror
squalid acts are always Justified with
some false dream about what they will
achieve
but they have never worked and they
never will
[Applause]
instead
let us glorify moderation
romanticize respect and make Heroes of
those with the courage to reject
absolutes not kill for them
now second Making Peace required leaps
of imagination
to conceive of a system for power
sharing between traditions
to design an agreement with three
strands of equal importance to enshrine
the principle of consent so that
Northern Ireland remains a part of the
United Kingdom for as long as its people
wish while protecting the aspirations of
those who seek a different future
through peaceful means
and for the first time the people of
North and South were both given the
opportunity to support the deal and they
did so in overwhelming majorities
and let us never forget the crucial work
after 1998 to build a broader consensus
helped by the leadership of Dr Ian
Paisley
and third
the peace took extraordinary
perseverance
in the aftermath of the shankill bomb
and gracel massacre in 1993 many thought
the peace process was over
but just two months later John Major and
Albert Reynolds delivered the Downing
Street declaration
George Mitchell persuaded all parties to
sign up to the principles of democracy
and non-violence without which the talks
could not have begun
and in the difficult Final hours
President Clinton's timely interventions
helped get the deal done and whenever
people walked away
Tony Blair sought to bring them back
always committed always attuned to the
concerns of all parts of the community
Hearn he showed us what's possible when
the UK and Irish governments work
together a partnership I know will
continue alongside my friend Leo varadka
and in the spirit of perseverance it's
also fitting to recognize the
contribution of the security forces now
like my predecessors
I acknowledge that at times they made
mistakes
but we must also recognize their bravery
suffering and sacrifice and that of the
police
without their courageous service there
would have been no peace process at all
they created the conditions that
ultimately allowed their own presence on
the streets to be reduced or entirely
withdrawn
so courage
imagination and perseverance
those qualities brought an imperfect but
enduring piece to a place taught to
believe no such peace was possible
so to all those who led us to that peace
including those in this Hall and those
no longer with us
let us take this moment to say to all of
you thank you
[Applause]
now for those of us like me who inherit
this extraordinary even intimidating
Legacy
our challenge today
is to fulfill the promise of the work
that you began
to honor your legacy
we need to create a more stable devolved
government in Northern Ireland and that
means getting the institutions up and
running
[Applause]
now I believe there are two tasks first
to remove the biggest block to the
institutions remain returning and that's
why when I came into office I made it a
priority to fix the Northern Ireland
protocol and we were deeply conscious of
the lessons of history as we did so
that's why our aims were to balance and
respect the aspirations of all parts of
the community protect the relationships
between East and West as much as north
and south and persist through careful
detailed negotiation
am I pay tribute to Ursula vondeline who
I'm so pleased to see here today
The Windsor framework is a breakthrough
moment it solves practical problems and
crucially strengthens Northern Ireland's
place in our Union and our UK internal
Market it gives the assembly significant
new powers ready for when it sits again
and I am confident we can build broad
support for it across all communities
so why share people's frustrations that
the institutions are not back up and
running
but that points to our second task
we must keep working to persuade all
parts of the community that returning to
the institutions is the best path
and we will do that we will talk we will
listen we will try to persuade and we
will not give up and I want to speak
directly for a moment to the
representatives of unionism who include
many diverse voices and whose concerns
with the protocol we are focused on
addressing
I urge you to work with us to get storm
on up and running again that's the right
thing to do in its own terms
and I'm convinced it's also the right
thing to do for our union now I'm a
proud unionist We passionately believe
that Northern Ireland is stronger within
the United Kingdom and the United
Kingdom is stronger with Northern
Ireland within it
but we must also build support Beyond
those of us who already identify as
unionists to do that we have to show
that devolved government within the
United Kingdom works for Northern
Ireland
[Applause]
you know the fact that the institutions
have been down for nine of the last 25
years should be a source of profound
concern
over the long term that will not bolster
the cause of unionism I believe that
deeply
so we need to get the institutions up
and running and keep them up and running
and let me also say to those who would
seek to reform the institutions right
now I understand your frustrations but
history reminds us that nothing in
Northern Ireland has ever been achieved
by trying to get around one Community or
another
so any conversation about reform can
only begin once the institutions are up
and running again and if it attracts
widespread consent
Belfast Good Friday agreement left us an
extraordinary and precious Legacy
when we look back in 25 years from now
surely we should Aspire for our Legacy
to be nothing less than this that the
institutions have been up and running
for every single year
because our Focus must be on the future
getting the institutions back up and
running is our most pressing challenge
to honor your legacy but that's only the
beginning
together we must fulfill the true
promise of the 1998 agreement
that future enshrined in the very words
of the text of sustained economic growth
and where we tackle the problems of a
divided Society
I will give everything to help deliver
that vision
because I talked earlier about learning
the lessons from history
one thing I took from George Mitchell is
the idea that the agreement itself is
only 20 of the task the rest is delivery
once the agreement was done people asked
of Tony Blair would he walk away
he didn't and neither will I
because
there is work to be done so let me tell
you what I'm going to do first economic
growth
progress has been remarkable in April
Northern Ireland had the highest
unemployment rate in the United Kingdom
today
it's the second lowest
but we need to do more in 25 years when
we look back I want to see that Northern
Ireland has changed
from an economy to reliant on the public
sector to a thriving Dynamic economy
built around the power and innovation of
private Enterprise
now I talk a lot about the idea of
leveling up
about making sure young people can feel
that they can fulfill their dreams and
aspirations in the place they call home
that idea has particular resonance here
in Northern Ireland
and we won't achieve it without a
Cascade of new investment to create jobs
and opportunity
Journey has already begun last week
President Biden came and told the world
to invest here
now he didn't say that out of
sentimentality he said it because he can
see the opportunity for American
businesses and because of the enormous
potential of this place
the potential of the people resilient
ingenious determined
the potential of your businesses with
world-class strengths and cyber Life
Sciences financial services and the
creative Industries and one of Europe's
Most thriving start-up scenes
I know that journey to Prosperity won't
be easy and we aren't there yet
but this is my commitment to you I will
use the full force and power of the UK
government to help you make one of this
the best places in the world to start
and grow a business create jobs train
and learn new skills and attract
investment
[Applause]
and just as we want to look back on a
more prosperous Dynamic economy
so in 25 years
I also want us to look back on a more
integrated and contented Society
now of course we cannot simply wish away
those social realities that have been
present for decades
the tragic loss of Lyra McKee and the
attack on DCI John Caldwell remind us
how far we still have to go
but people are already voting with their
feet in the choices they make for their
children's education and in their social
and sporting lives
a growing body of the electorate does
not define themselves solely as
unionists or nationalists British or
Irish
a growing portion of people sample life
in different parts of these islands but
still return
and a growing number of local
communities are signaling that their
patients with thuggery is over
but there's yet more to do
in 25 years
should not the poisonous grip of the
palamilitaries those gangsters and drug
dealers who wrap themselves in the fake
cloak of legitimacy be broken once and
for all
in 25 years
should not a fragment of a peaceful be
nothing more than a stop on the tourist
Trail
and in 25 years
should integrated education not be the
norm rather than the exception
[Applause]
of course
we won't build that better future
overnight
and it won't always be easy
every time I visit Northern Ireland
I feel more optimistic and hopeful
because to paraphrase the late David
Trimble
there may be Hills ahead of us but there
are mountains behind
and I want to close by reflecting on an
extraordinary story
just weeks before the agreement
two lifelong friends
Damien trainer and Philip Allen were
murdered at points pass
one was a Protestant
the other Catholic
now the people who murdered them may
have hoped to sow chaos and Division and
derail the peace talks
they failed
because the story of this remarkable
friendship inspired one of the most
decisive breakthroughs of the whole
peace process
the agreement to share power between
equal first and Deputy first ministers
in a co-creme ship with one from each
community
as Mark Durkin the sdlp's lead
negotiator said at the time
the stories
of Philip and Damien's special
friendship
could be a parable
for the sort of society that we might
create if we could reach agreement
and he was right
that is the promise of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement
and together we can
and we must fulfill it thank you
[Applause]
I wish to see that the Prime Minister
there addressing the audience at Queen's
University Belfast commemorating the
25th anniversary of the Good Friday
agreement he said circumstances
um in Northern Ireland at the moment are
far from perfect institutions need to
get up and running again the keynote
speakers at this conference have
reflected not just on the past but the
present and the future of Northern
Ireland he echoed the former U.S
President Bill Clinton who was on that
stage a little earlier who essentially
said that Northern Ireland needs to get
the show back on the road because of
course Stormwind is not sitting it
hasn't been for some time